(whooshing)
- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat music)
- Good afternoon, my name is Marvin Cohen.
I'm a Professor of
Physics here at Berkeley
and I'm pleased to
introduce Dr Ralph Cicerone
who will present the second
Hitchcock lecture today.
Yesterday when he introduced Dr Cicerone,
Professor Vincent Resh
reviewed the background
regarding the creation of the
Charles and Martha Hitchcock
Lecture Series.
I won't repeat what he said
except for echoing his statement
that we feel that the
Hitchcock Fund has been one
of the most cherished endowments
of the University of California
recognizing the highest
distinction of scholarly
thought and achievement.
Dr Ralph J. Cicerone is president
of the National Academy of Sciences
and chair of the National
Research Council.
His research, which focuses
on atmospheric chemistry
climate change and trace gases,
resulted in his making
fundamental contributions
to our understanding of greenhouse gases
and ozone depletion.
In addition, he has been credited
with shaping science and
environmental policy,
both nationally and internationally.
His achievements in research
and in his public policy leadership
in protecting the global
environment have been recognized
with many awards such
as the 1999 Bauer Award
and the prize for achievement in science
from the Franklin Institute.
In 2001, he led a National
Academy of Sciences study
on the current state of climate change
requested by President Bush.
After obtaining degrees from MIT
and the University of Illinois,
Dr Cicerone was associated with
the University of Michigan,
our sister university, UC San Diego,
and the Scripps Institute,
the National Center
for Atmospheric Research
in Boulder, Colorado,
and, in 1989, he joined another UC campus.
He joined the faculty at UC Irvine
where he served as a
professor, a chair, a Dean
and then the Chancellor
and he did it very rapidly.
That's where I first met Ralph,
during my visits to Irvine to do physics
with the faculty there
and to sit on committees.
I recall how happy I was when
he agreed to run for election
and was elected in 2005 as president
of the National Academy of Sciences.
Throughout his years as
president of the NAS,
I've watched Ralph handle
an incredibly large number
of complex problems and issues,
many going well beyond science.
For those of you who heard his
wonderful lecture yesterday,
you will understand what
I mean when I describe him
as knowing all the facts,
using sound arguments and logic,
presenting information in a
non-confrontational manner
and slowly showing you the correct path.
And you end up thinking
that's the only correct path
because he does such a good job.
His yearly speeches at
the NAS annual meetings
on the state of science are marvelous.
Yesterday's lecture
focused on a discussion
related to up-to-date
data on climate change.
Today, he will compare
successful initiatives
that protect the ozone layer
and, this is a subject where a great deal
of the basic science was
done here at Berkeley,
with unsuccessful, at
least to date, initiatives
to stabilize global climate.
So, please join me in
welcoming Dr Ralph Cicerone.
(audience clapping)
- Well, thank you, Professor Cohen.
I look forward to today's time with you
because I'm going to take
a rather different path
than I did yesterday.
As Professor Cohen said, I
focused a lot on field data,
things that are being
measured around the world,
temperatures and
precipitation and so forth,
sea level and ice loss and so forth,
fairly factual, although,
very stunning too
how much has been learned
and what it all adds up to.
But, today, I want to focus on the topic
which is summarized there in the title
because a lot of us wonder
what are the differences?
Why was the world able
to come to an agreement
that's old enough now that
some of you in the room
are not as old as the agreement is,
let alone the phenomenon that preceded it.
But, nonetheless, it's quite striking.
A lot of books have been written
about what's called the Montreal Protocol
and how well it has acted to protect
the atmospheric ozone layer
and, subsequently then,
things that are affected,
living things that are affected
by increased ultraviolet light.
And then why it's been so difficult
to reach any effective agreement
on limiting climate change.
And when I received this
wonderful invitation
to come to deliver a Hitchcock lecture,
I thought I'd really
like to try that topic.
Some opinion is mixed in.
You'll see that this is not so much facts.
There haven't been
really any serious books
written on the subject,
but let me give it a try.
So, what I'll do quickly is
to sketch out the similarities
between these two global
international situations
where human activities
are demonstrably affecting
the environment in largely harmful ways
and how it is that the
public reacted to them.
What were the ingredients?
Why did the political
action go the way it did?
Why did the corporate world
behave the way it did?
Why do we end up with such
an effective protection
of the ozone layer and
we're still struggling
with climate change quite mightily?
I'll give you a hint, though.
When I wrote down this
title, I hadn't yet studied
what came out of Paris in December
and, after I've thought about
the Paris Climate Agreement
of 2015, I'm more optimistic.
There are some extremely
intelligent provisions
written into that, what
will become a treaty.
So, I'll make some contrast
and then I'll talk about each
of these issues a little bit
and then give you my score sheet of why
it's turned out so differently.
And part of it has to do with cartoons
that appear in newspapers and magazines.
So, the outline is I'll
give you a quick sketch
of these two global
environmental problems,
the rudiments of them, and
then to start to compare
public and governmental responses
and then talk at the end
more about the international
framework we have to deal with
the climate issue and what
just has come out of Paris
and where it stands.
So, the ozone layer.
Professor Cohen just mentioned that some
of the most important
research on this topic
happened here at Berkeley.
Certainly, not all of it, but
some very important things,
largely due to Professor Harold Johnston,
now a deceased faculty
member in chemistry,
but, at the time all
this started around 1970,
we didn't know much about
ozone in the atmosphere.
It had been discovered
a hundred years before,
but what it was doing there?
How it got produced?
What limits?
It was not known, but it was
known that the natural layer
of ozone exists up in the upper atmosphere
and that it absorbs, as a gas,
it absorbs ultraviolet light.
And the Sun sending us sunlight
does emit ultraviolet light.
So, the ozone layer plays a major part
in absorbing ultraviolet
light from the Sun,
which if were not absorbed
up in the upper atmosphere,
would come down to the
surface of the Earth
where it can interact, not
only causes skin cancer
in light-skinned people, but
other kinds of skin damage
and surface damage to plants
and it makes cracks in your
windshield wiper blades
and car tires.
That's why modern rubber
today has UV stabilizers
built into the rubber, things like this.
Nuisance.
Just about that time, though,
the first laboratory studies
of typical biochemicals,
including small organisms
and cells, were being studied
and found that ultraviolet
light of the same wavelength
that is absorbed by ozone, breaks down
typical protein molecules and
causes skin cancer in humans
and in some animals.
And as a kind of secondary
part of the climate system,
when ozone absorbs that ultraviolet light,
it heats the upper atmosphere and creates
the temperature structure
of the upper atmosphere.
These things were all kind
of known qualitatively,
but not too much was known.
So, a couple of us who were moving
from one scientific field to another
decided to look into the ozone layer
because it sounded interesting
and not much was known
and we could get going
on something quickly.
And, rather soon, we came up with an idea
that, if somehow chlorine atoms
could enter the ozone layer,
several reactions would occur.
And we had to do a lot of
sorting out to get here,
but a chlorine atom reacts with ozone
and makes a chlorine monoxide molecule
plus, at normal oxygen, the sunlight
is always hitting ozone.
For example, visible light to
release an oxygen atom and O2
and the third reaction closes this,
what's now seen to be a chain.
The CLO that was produced
in the first reaction
now reacts in the third reaction
and you'll see that this is like a cycle.
You can add these up and the net result
is that two ozone molecules
and a photon of light
have become three oxygen molecules.
So, this is a neat way to destroy ozone.
It's a principle of catalysis.
Industrial chemists use it all the time.
It's used in car exhausts now
to catalytically destroy nitrogen oxides.
So, we knew we had found
something interesting
and the trick was is there any chlorine
in the upper atmosphere.
At the same time, Mario Molina,
who had just finished graduate
school here at Berkeley
and had moved down to Irvine
with his colleague, Sherry
Rowland, came up with an idea
that there was a class of
chemicals that humans had created,
purely synthetic chemicals
called chlorofluoromethanes,
that are inert enough
that they're building up
in the lower atmosphere
and that, in normal course
of events, they could drift upwards
into the upper atmosphere,
intact, not being destroyed,
where they could be broken
apart and chlorine atoms
would fall out of them and
then they would proceed
to destroy ozone.
So, these people discovered
what we had just discovered
several months before,
but they had a much more important story,
namely that humans were
doing something already
and, in the amounts being
used, these chemical reactions
are so effective that there
could be significant harm
to the ozone layer.
So, they published this
in a British Journal
and everybody paid attention immediately.
These chemicals, the
chlorofluorocarbons as I said,
were synthetic.
Even though they were produced
by only a few companies worldwide,
their sales growth rates were
about 15% per year worldwide.
The U.S. aerosol spray can market
was about a billion cans a year,
hair sprays, deodorants.
There was even a product
that delivered catnip
in a spray can with CFCs and
these were very popular items.
They had originally been
invented, these chemicals,
as refrigeration fluids to replace
what were really some
nasty and toxic fluids
in old time refrigerators.
So, these chemicals were
seen as a success story
and their sales and market
were just taking off.
You'll see the chemical names
of a couple of them here.
They were essentially inert.
They were designed to be inert.
They were built to be inert.
If you put a propellant in a
spray can, with say, perfume,
you don't want the propellant to interact
with the perfume and
change its color and smell.
You want the propellant to be inert.
They were designed to be
that way and they were,
but what Molina and Roland pointed out,
and they came up here to Berkeley
to visit with Hal Johnston
to see if he could poke any
holes in what they had proposed,
was that the ultimate
fate of these chemicals
in the Earth's atmosphere
is they would survive rain.
They would survive clouds.
They would survive attack
by other chemicals.
They wouldn't be oxidized,
but they would go up into the ozone layer,
be torn apart by that same
kind of energetic UV light
and release chlorine atoms
and that then would trigger
this catalytic cycle against ozone.
Well, when this idea was first proposed,
we knew virtually nothing
about this whole system
and a lot of people just scoffed
and said, you've got to be crazy.
This little spray can that I'm using
is somehow gonna be dangerous worldwide.
It was a completely unacceptable notion,
but the public reaction
turned out to be very strong
over the next few years.
Incidentally, these CFC
molecules were discovered
to be strong greenhouse gases in 1975
and, when that was discovered,
nobody believed it either.
This is just a sketch of what happens.
So, just like with climate change now,
there were very common claims being made.
In fact, I gave a seminar
in a physics department,
I think it was the University of Michigan,
where the faculty basically
scoffed at these ideas
using some of these phrases
that are about to follow.
I've put them all in quotation marks
because they're not facts.
They were what people
were claiming at the time.
First of all, these chemicals
are heavier than air.
They won't rise into the stratosphere.
Well, we had learned in
the 1940s, for god's sake,
that the lowest 100 kilometers
of the Earth's atmosphere
is fully mixed, gravitational separation
has nothing to do with it,
molecules like argon and carbon dioxide
were found high in the
atmosphere in the same fractions
as the third surface.
So, that's just an example of how people,
their knee-jerk reaction, was this idea
cannot possibly be right.
They will not rise into the stratosphere.
That there are large
natural sources of CFCs,
such as volcanoes.
There weren't.
Many of us went out into volcanoes
and actually tried to find this stuff.
There weren't.
There are large natural sources
of similar chlorine-containing gases.
That's virtually wrong,
but there's one exception.
That, even so, chlorine
will not destroy ozone
and the CFC source is too small to matter.
There were more of these things.
Stratospheric ozone behavior
is too complicated to calculate.
Why do you even do these calculations?
They're gonna be wrong.
That there are other causes of skin cancer
besides ultraviolet light.
And ultraviolet light is good for you.
All kinds of statements like this.
Chemicals are innocent
until proven guilty.
Consumers want aerosol spray products.
Well, that was an interesting one
because there was a book written
about the aerosol industry
that documented how much,
quote, consumer resistance
there was to aerosol spray cans.
And some of the examples given
were with underarm spray deodorants
that people really didn't
like being hit in the armpit
by a spray of cold air.
So, there had to be massive
advertising campaigns mounted
to overcome that resistance.
Yes, some people liked these
products for their convenience,
but the fact that the consumers had voted
that they wanted these products,
turned out not to be right
because, far long before there
were government regulations
and edicts, the market for these compounds
started to drop off largely
due to people speaking
and saying, you know,
if there's any chance
that these scientists are right,
why don't we just quit using these things?
We can have a pump bottle
with hairspray in it.
We've got substitutes.
We don't need these things.
And then the one of the
silliest ones of all,
Molina and Roland are computer modelers.
Well, they were both
laboratory physical chemists.
I didn't know what a computer looked like.
Now, an important fact
that will come out later,
is that this success story
of these synthetic chemicals,
which really were useful as refrigerants
and air-conditioning fluids, were produced
by only a few companies around the world.
I'll just list their names here,
six largely in the United States,
where most of the market was.
Now, when this story became widespread,
I was told at one congressional hearing
that Congress was receiving more mail
on this chlorofluorocarbon ozone problem
than they had ever received on any subject
since the second World War.
So, there was great public
awareness and Pogo cartoon
picked it up in three
or four different ones.
I don't know if you can read that,
but it says the ozone layer is up there,
between eight and 30 miles,
and it's being depleted by man,
and the turtle says, how?
Oh, by exhaust from jet
planes, high altitude testing
of nuclear bombs and inert
gases from spray cans.
How can anything way up there be harmed
by a little old spray can?
Billions of them, Churchy.
So, it goes on and on.
So, there was a tremendous
uptake and illustration
of the principles in daily
and weekly magazines,
year after year.
Another one was Jim Berry
who was a famous cartoon.
The previous one you'll recognize
was the Kelly family who did Pogo.
This one from Jim Berry, the
boy's telling his father,
you realize, of course,
what does that say?
That what you're doing to the ozone hole,
what you did to the passenger pigeon.
Bill Mauldin, who was the cartoonist
who invented GI Joe in
the second World War,
was very popular and showing
all these atomic bombs,
I guess, and he says,
oh, so the aerosol bomb,
that's the one that's
most likely to get us.
And then, an important feature,
was cartoonists started to criticize
the chlorofluorocarbon
chemical manufacturers.
True, the fluorocarbon industry's
threat to the ozone layer
may very well be serious,
but the ozone layer's threat
to the fluorocarbon
industry is equally serious.
And this begins to pick
up an important point.
From the public's point
of view, they could blame
this problem on a few producers.
Nobody else, no other natural process,
was producing these chemicals,
but you could point to
a list of six companies
in the United States that were producing
most of the world's chlorofluorocarbons
and that made it easy
for people to say, well,
I wouldn't be harmed if
we just got rid of these,
if I could keep my refrigerator
and my air-conditioner.
Let's get rid of all the rest.
Then later, another
important element is in 1985.
A discovery was made
looking down on the Earth
from a remote sensing satellite
and, looking up from the
Earth from Antarctica,
it was discovered that
there was a big hole
in the ozone layer over Antarctica.
There aren't even any people there.
So, it illustrated the
point, on the one hand,
that chemicals do survive
journeys around the Earth,
but it also showed that
there were surprises.
And this was very much a scientific issue.
And, by the way, the
scientists missed this.
The scientists did not predict this.
They did not understand
this sudden appearance
of the ozone layer.
So, from a public point of view,
very much an element here of the unknown.
This was not a political issue.
They could see that science was involved.
Discoveries were being made.
In fact, the first people who
should have seen the ozone,
all threw away the data.
They didn't believe the data
and it took other groups
to come along who actually
made this discovery.
So, there was an element
of discovery and science.
I'm just talking a little bit about
what we learned about the ozone hole.
Another cartoon, this is a
take-off on Little Orphan Annie.
The Sun will come out tomorrow
and then the Sun comes out
because there's an ozone hole
and all the ultraviolet comes
down and scorches everything.
These cartoonists had a big impact.
I cannot tell you how much mail I got,
people responding to cartoons.
A lot of what I'm saying
is well-documented.
This is one of the best books
ever written about a saga like this
and how the international
negotiations came into play,
written by a United States
State Department Ambassador,
Richard Benedict, who
was one of the key people
in negotiating the
international agreements.
This was during the Reagan administration.
Ronald Reagan was president
and Reagan supported these
international negotiations.
In fact, helped to lead the way toward
the international agreement
to ban chlorofluorocarbons.
But this book, called Ozone
Diplomacy by Richard Benedict,
I think it's published
around 1992, it's good.
There a couple of other
books that can document
pretty much everything I'm saying.
Although, I think they
miss the tremendous impact
of local consumer groups.
My wife Carol and I will remember
that there was a young
man, about 23 years old,
who took on a crusade of getting rid
of aerosol spray products.
He called it the clean air movement
and he went around giving
demonstrations to people
that the cans of aerosol
products they were buying
were 85 to 90% by weight, propellant,
and they weren't getting much product.
So, he pointed to this
danger to the ozone layer
and, in many states, there
were local and state movements
to get rid of these chemicals.
People had said we don't
need this chance anymore.
These unpredicted things are happening.
We're getting afraid.
We don't need these products.
So, that was the genesis of
how the federal government
could enter the situation.
In many states, state
governments were threatening,
including California, to unilaterally ban
the sale, distribution and
production of these chemicals.
So, some of the chemical
manufacturers decided
that it would be better for them to accept
a well-founded federal
regulation rather than trying
to fight the tattered fabric
of 50 different state regulations.
And these books describe
all of these things.
So, in late 1987, in
Montreal, there was a meeting
that brought people together
from all over the world
who had been discussing this
issue in their home countries
and they actually agreed to a protocol
which became an international treaty.
The first step was a schedule
to phase out the production
and consumption of these
chlorofluorocarbon chemicals
with an agreed-upon schedule
that the first two compounds
listed, or the first three,
would be phased out slowly.
After two or three years,
their production and sales
would be limited to, I don't
know, something like 75%
of what it had been
and then this agreement
provided for subsequent reviews.
So, the countries of the
world actually agreed
that they would limit and
police this production,
make it illegal, but they
would come back together,
three or four years later,
to see if the information
still justified it or did they overreact,
in which case, you could
cut back on the regulations,
leave the chemical manufacturers alone,
continue to use the chemicals.
But, if on the other hand,
the scientific information,
every two or three or four
years, would become more definite
and, perhaps, more
threatening, then the agreement
could be tuned and tightened.
Well, by 1990, I think it
was Prime Minister Thatcher,
in London, demanded a
reconvening because the evidence
had come in that things were worse.
The evidence that the ozone layer
was being degraded by
these CFCs got stronger.
So, they modified this
protocol in all of these years,
1991, 1993, 1995, '97,
signed by 190 nations
and there is now a complete ban
on the two or three major
compounds and a pretty strong ban
on all of the others including
some compounds that contain
bromine that have the
same characteristics.
So, because the scientific information
kept getting more certain
and more threatening,
this protocol had this revision provision
that would allow a complete review
of whether the situation
looked less threatening
or more threatening with a
schedule for making it tighter
or looser and this was a brilliant,
and I think Ambassador Benedict
deserves a lot of the credit,
although, it was President
Reagan who really permitted
and authorized the State
Department to enter
into this kind of Montreal Protocol.
Before the protocol, though,
there had been international
scientific meetings
that the phrase, the term
of art, is assessment
where all the information
is brought together,
peer-reviewed scientific publications
from all over the world.
People were supposed to
become familiar with them
and criticize them and adopt
some common understanding.
And that kind of cycle had
been undertaken several times.
I think it was 1984, 1986, 1989, 1991,
every three, four, five
years, there would be more
of these international gatherings
with some really top notch scientists
arguing with each other.
I remember, this is a
little bit off the point,
but, originally, the British
were a little put out
because they hadn't
discovered the problem.
So, they were a little slow
to agree with everybody else,
but when their scientists started making
important contributions,
including the discovery
of the Antarctic ozone hole,
they changed their mind
and this had now become something
that they had discovered.
So, they agreed.
And there were language
problems with scientists
from other countries before, basically,
everybody was speaking English.
I mean, before that happened,
but there were language problems.
An interesting point is the
protocol with all of its teeth
was enacted before there was
any evidence of actual harm
to humans or to any living thing.
There's a minor exception to that,
but this point is mostly right.
So, this entire international agreement
with binding legal
requirements was enacted
before there was any evidence of damage.
Think about that.
And it was enacted before
this chlorine mechanism
was proven to cause the
Antarctic ozone hole.
So, it was really very far-reaching,
but maybe the provision
of it that was important
was that everybody agreed you
can come back and re-argue it
every two or three years.
If we're wrong, take it away.
If we're right, make it stronger.
So, that provision was a stroke of genius.
So, this is just a
graphical way of showing you
that the protocol has worked.
For this chemical chlorofluorocarbon 11,
the year is 1990, '95, 2000, 2005.
The amount that's
measured in the atmosphere
is decreasing with time.
That particular chemical will survive
in the atmosphere, 75, 80 years.
So, it takes a long time
for nature to destroy it.
So, we're not putting
any more into the air,
but it's coming down
slowly just as predicted.
And the same with the other two.
So, it's evidence that
the protocol has worked.
Now, yesterday, I talked somewhat
about what's observed
about climate change,
but this graph is a kind
of iconic symbol of it,
the increasing carbon dioxide
in Earth's atmosphere,
which many of you are very familiar with,
but now I want to talk a
little bit about climate change
and what we know, in less detail,
and then some of the
similarities and dissimilarities.
So, the major driving force, of course,
is the worldwide usage of fossil fuels
and the result being that
we inject a great deal
of carbon dioxide as carbon,
10 billion tons a year now,
into the air worldwide and
it comes from the burning
of coal, the burning of
petroleum, natural gas,
and the production of cement and so forth.
The point is that this
is a major disturbance.
The numbers have been
quantified pretty well
and their impacts, they're
being estimated, of course,
but the estimates are
converging on what looks
to be a serious problem.
So, the driving force is human activity.
There's lots and lots and
lots of evidence to present,
to show, why that's true
for this greenhouse gas
carbon dioxide and several others,
but I want to skim over that today.
We've had a series of serious
international assessments.
Each one of these booklets,
a cover of which I'm showing,
runs to be about a thousand pages
and there are a
thousand-page additions to it
that look not only at the
physical science basis,
the one that I'm showing here,
but also what humans can do
to mitigate and to
decrease climate change,
how to adapt to it.
And these assessments have been done
fairly carefully now since 1990.
The last one was released in 2013,
but 1990, 1995, 2001, 2007 and 2013.
And, after these four or
five dress rehearsals,
I would say that they're
pretty high quality.
They are as good a survey
of the published literature
as probably any one of you
could find in any field
that you've worked in.
Thousands, thousands of
scientists do the work
and every single critical argument
and criticism of the draft
versions are addressed
and made public.
So, it's done about as
well as we can do it.
So, in that respect, these
two problems are the same.
They've had tremendous
international attention,
probably not enough, but
still about as much as people
could bring together.
It's been done repeatedly.
So, it's not just a one-shot affair.
The ozone assessments look like this
and they happened every four years or so
over the last 30 years,
but now let's compare
the solutions a little bit.
In the case of ozone depletion,
and here's where my opinion
is gonna start to come out,
I think the framing of the
issue has been very different.
I'll start on the right
side with climate change.
Pretty much every time you see a story
written about climate change,
it might have a headline
that science is questionable,
but then within six
words of the beginning,
it starts to talk about politics
and economic costs, for example.
So, the framing of the issue,
in the case of ozone depletion,
was as a scientific issue.
There are a lot of unknowns,
a lot of things to be discovered.
There are surprises, but in
the case of climate change,
it's as if everybody's an expert
and we can just jump
off to political action
and assume that regulations
are going to be unbearable
and we're supposed to talk
about politics and regulations
and ignore the scientific part of it,
but this is what public relations
people would call framing.
What is the first instinct
you have when you hear
about a new issue?
If it's been framed as a
mystery or a scientific issue,
you'll have a different set of reactions
than if it's been framed
as a political one
where you're gonna have
to make bad choices.
The second thing is how, from
a scientific point of view,
do you test this theory?
Well, in the case of the ozone
layer, the ozone depletion,
there was what was called a smoking gun.
The scientific community agreed in 1974
that the smoking gun of this theory
would be if you could
simultaneously measure
these two chemicals,
chlorine monoxide and ozone,
and they were roughly
in the right amounts,
what was predicted,
everything else was solid,
and everything else would follow.
But, in the case of climate change,
we're talking about many variables
that are important to us.
Temperatures, wind, sea
level, precipitation.
Are the seasons going
to stay where they are?
Is the growing season going
to be extended or shrunk?
Things like that.
So, there is, inherently,
a longer list of variables
that have to be measured
and it's hard to come up
with a smoking gun.
How can you, with one
observation, or one variable
test everything that's being
said about climate change?
I don't think you can,
especially, if you think
about the indirect, but still
potentially serious effects,
like public health matters.
Health effects.
The ozone depletion layer
was framed immediately
in terms of a cancer.
This is what caught people's attention,
especially, amongst white-skinned people
because they're the
ones who are vulnerable.
Darker-skinned people have
more melanin that absorbs
the ultraviolet before it
hits the internal cells.
So, this issue was framed
as a skin cancer issue
and many, many of the
articles and discussions
were about human cancer.
That's pretty scary and it had an impact.
Even though it's true
that ultraviolet light
and sunburn does not
cause all skin cancers,
it still is a demonstrated
cause of many skin cancers
With climate change, I
think it's hard to come up
with a direct health effect.
You have to get into the arguments,
in a pretty sophisticated
way, to say, you know,
there are going to be health
effects of climate change.
I'll give you one example which
has those characteristics.
In 2003, there was a major
heat wave around Paris
in, I think, it was July,
and when this heat wave
broke after six weeks,
the Parisian officials
and the provinces around there,
estimated that something
like 40,000 people,
I think it was, 30 or 40,000 people,
had died under heat stress and dehydration
during that heat wave.
And it's pretty well-documented.
It largely had to do with elderly people
living in flats and apartments
that didn't have good
circulation and air-conditioning
and they were being put under
respiratory and heat stress.
So, I would say that's a
pretty big health impact,
but it's pretty subtle.
It's only happened under
these extreme conditions.
There was a heat wave in Chicago in 1995
that caused similarly pretty
well-documented deaths,
but for the most part, when
we think about climate change,
we're not talking about health effects
and what do you expect the public to do
when they hear about one issue
that has a cancerous impact
and the other with
maybe no health effects?
That was another reason why we've ended up
with different solutions
to these problems,
at least, in general.
The complexity.
We now look at the ozone layer
and realize it was really pretty simple.
There are some people here in the audience
who are working on much
more difficult problems
in atmospheric chemistry,
but, at the time, the ozone layer was,
turns out to be pretty
simple, less complex,
and pretty much a global picture.
Worldwide, everything was
gonna be roughly the same.
In the case of climate change,
we've got natural and
historic variability.
We know there have been
big climate changes before
that have resulted in big
impacts in certain regions,
certain periods of time.
It's been natural and,
therefore, climate change
is playing out against that background.
That is, the human-caused climate change
is being superimposed on a system
where there's already natural
and historical variability
that humans have been subjected to.
That there are local differences.
In fact, we have this
urban heat island now
where it's hotter in the middle
of the city, day and night,
than it is in the surrounding areas
and a major source of complexity
is that, in the climate
system, part of the system
is living organisms,
plants, microbes and humans,
for that matter, whereas
with the ozone layer,
to a first approximation,
it was a physical system.
When you introduce life into a system,
things become more complicated.
Another one, guilty parties.
I've already more than hinted at this.
In the case of the chlorofluorocarbons,
I could name the companies
even after all these years.
There's so few of them.
They were producing the chemicals.
They had invented them.
They were selling them.
They were making lots of money,
but in the case of climate change,
to take the major source of
climate change, carbon dioxide,
it's every single user of
fossil fuels around the world.
That's seven billion of us.
When you wanted to know
who the guilty party was,
in the case of the ozone layer,
you could point to those companies.
Who's the guilty party in
the case of climate change?
You know, you can look in the mirror.
To continue, how big was
this need in the first place?
In the case of the chlorofluorocarbons,
we didn't really need
them in aerosol products.
There was one exemption given
in that ban that I remember,
producers of aerosol
products that carry fine
diamond dust in it for highly
specialized applications
in cleaning of jewelry
and things like that,
but for the most part,
these chlorofluorocarbons
were unnecessary.
They could be replaced by spray products.
You know, handheld pumps and so forth.
The CFCs as refrigerants
and air-conditioners,
for goodness sake, Florida
wouldn't have anywhere
near the population it has now,
if it weren't for air-conditioners
and parts of California for that matter.
Electricity use in California
is driven by air-conditioners.
You can go to the Public
Utilities Commission
and see the data on electrical consumption
on hot days in California.
But, for fossil fuels, we're talking about
more essential issues.
For generating electricity,
which until recently,
has been dominated by coal,
generation of electricity.
And, fortunately, some renewable fuels
are helping out on that front now
and natural gas, which is less dirty,
but the point is heating,
lighting, electricity
and transportation are pretty essential.
So, it's harder to find substitutes
and it's especially hard to
find substitutes that can handle
the electricity needs
and transportation needs
of the whole world, let's say, next year.
We had a nice discussion here yesterday
with some people over when
will we see mass substitutions
for gasoline and diesel
fuel, and it's in sight,
but it's not gonna be in
the next five or 10 years.
Are substitutes available?
Well, as it turned out,
there are now substitute
aerosol propellants
and there's substitute refrigerants.
They're slightly more
complicated chemicals
that have a hydrogen atom or
more in each of the molecules,
instead of just chlorine and fluorine.
Some of them are so successful
that they can be seen to cause
no damage to the ozone layer.
There's some greenhouse gas effect.
They're cheap.
They've been able to
use the same compressors
and cooling units in car
and truck air-conditioners
and so forth.
So, the substitutes have
been a major success,
and here, I think the DuPont company
deserves a lot of credit for developing
these substitutes in a hurry
when the Montreal Protocol
really was looming, coming
down the road at them.
And the substitutes for climate change.
The substitutes are in
sight like renewable energy,
wind and solar and hydro power
and maybe safe nuclear power,
not so clear, but not to
the scale that we need,
at least, not immediately.
So, people in responding what
to do about these two issues,
they think about all of these things.
The first question economist would ask
is there a substitute for the substance
that you're talking about, for example.
These international
assessments, I just said,
were roughly the same, high-quality,
international involvement,
subject to rigorous peer-review.
Roughly on par there.
So, that's one of the reasons
why a lot of scientists ask,
look, we've done a good
job on these assessments,
why can't we just have an
international agreement
on climate change.
Well, it's all of these
other things are involved.
How many defenders were there of the CFCs?
Frankly, only a few manufacturers
and a few aerosol spray can people,
whereas, there are some serious
defenders of fossil fuels,
the petroleum and mining interests
and, more modern, these
anti-government attitudes
thinking that any kind
of regulatory action
is somehow not acceptable.
So, and you've probably seen analyses
of how much resistance there
is, organized resistance,
that try to undercut the
science and try to oppose
any kind of organized action.
There was a cartoon on that 2001 report
that Professor Cohen mentioned,
the White House didn't respond
very well to our report.
There was a Berkeley faculty member
on that committee with me, Inez Fung,
who I don't think is here
today, but she will remember,
and this was a great cartoon that,
we got the original of it, didn't you?
You got it from that guy in Akron, yeah.
Now, where do we stand on climate change?
The original United Nations
Framework Convention
on Climate Change signed
by President Bush,
George HW Bush, the first
Bush, stated right up front
that the ultimate objective of
this convention is to achieve
stabilization of greenhouse
gas concentrations
in the atmosphere at a
level that would prevent
dangerous anthropogenic interference
with the climate system.
It's a pretty clear statement
of what the goal is.
However, since 1992, it has
not been possible to agree
on what is a dangerous level
of greenhouse gas concentrations
and then to devise actions to achieve it.
This group, the official
delegates of all the UN Nations,
190 nations, has met
about 20 times since 1992,
15 or 20, and they haven't
made much progress.
In the 1990s, they
agreed on what was called
the Kyoto Protocol from a
meeting in Kyoto, Japan,
and it was never accepted
in the United States.
President Clinton didn't even
take the treaty to the Senate
where he had to get it confirmed.
I think the assumed vote was
gonna be about 95 to nothing
against his proposal, had he done it.
So, he never even took it to
the Senate, as I remember,
but the original goal was clear, as I say,
and it's hard even from a
scientific point of view
to define with a simple
number what is the safe level
of greenhouse gases in the atmosphere.
We might agree that whatever there was
before the Industrial Revolution was safe.
We know what those numbers
are, but this assumes,
and the fact is we're already
well above that number.
So, it's hard to know what to shoot for,
but now the Paris agreement,
which the more I got into it,
the more optimistic I began to come.
Of course, your reaction
to a document like this
depends on your original expectation.
My expectation was low,
but after thinking about
all of these things, I
feel more optimistic.
First of all, the goal.
The goal continues to
be the original goal,
to prevent dangerous
anthropogenic interference
with climate stability,
but they've come up with
a specific line, to limit the global
average temperature rise
to two degrees centigrade
and this is largely a
European-driven target.
There's been, I would
say, more work in Europe
and the scientific
community to try to estimate
what the impacts would be and, of course,
it's not the global average temperature
that really causes all of
this, but as a proxy measure,
the level of greenhouse
gases can be specified
as those that would cause the
global average temperature
to rise two degrees.
So, what I'm saying is you
don't have to agree with this,
but it is a real step forward
in terms of specifying
what a dangerous level should be.
The way they propose, in
the Paris Climate Agreement,
to reach that level of stability
is not legally binding.
The treaty does not say the
United States shall do this
and shall not do that
or China shall do this
and shall not do that.
Although, the word shall
was apparently a source
of great argument amongst the diplomats.
Every time there's a treaty to be written,
they argue over whether things
should be shall or should,
but, in this case, the
principle is different.
Before the meeting, they
agreed that every country,
participating in the Paris discussions,
would bring to the table
voluntary national commitments
to limit the emissions of greenhouse gases
and the greenhouse gases
are very sensibly defined
as carbon dioxide, methane,
nitrous oxide, some CFCs,
and a few others, the so-called basket
of six or seven chemicals.
So, if a nation comes forward,
like say, New Zealand,
whose principal emission
of greenhouse gases
is through methane from sheep,
if they could propose to limit that enough
that could be an acceptable,
I'm just picking that out of the air,
that could be an acceptable contribution,
if they could voluntarily
commit to limit the emissions
of that particular greenhouse gas.
I do have what the United
States committed to
and we can talk about it earlier,
but in the treaty language,
these are called
nationally-determined contributions.
So, the leaders of the
countries like the United States
can tell the public and the Congress,
we determine this contribution.
The other nations of the world
didn't tell us what to do.
These are nationally-determined
and all 190 nations delivered
these nationally-determined contributions.
Now, the fact is what
was delivered to Paris
is not going to stabilize
the climate change
to less than two degrees,
but what's very interesting
is they've adopted some of the features
of the Montreal Protocol,
whereby, there will be assessments
and estimates by experts,
without political interference,
of the numbers.
Are your estimates viable?
You're saying that
you'll cut your emissions
by a certain fraction compared
to the year 2010 or 1990.
Well, how well can you
establish that baseline?
So, this third point, assess
each nation's progress
towards its nationally-determined
contribution.
All 187 nations, everyone has now agreed
that their assessment and their
estimates will be reviewed
by technically-competent
people internationally
on a periodic basis, every two years,
something like that.
This is real progress because
the Kyoto Protocol from 1997
did not have any requirements
on developing countries.
The entire burden was on
so-called rich countries.
They had to achieve all the goals
that were set to them legally,
but there were no requirements,
even for reporting,
from the developing countries.
So, in this one, the richer nations won
by getting all the countries to agree
that there will be a
technically-competent assessment
of how much progress you're making
toward your nationally-determined
contribution.
I think this is really progress
and the estimates
themselves will be analyzed
for quality and fidelity and
honesty by technical experts.
This whole process will
be iterated on a schedule
roughly every five years, if not sooner.
There will be new efforts
and the assumption
and the commitment is you
will now lower your emissions
to achieve a tighter bound
of 1.5 degrees centigrade
on the global average temperature.
Something that the poorer
nations insisted on
is they want money from
the richer nations,
but this has always been the case,
but the goal now is to create a fund
of a hundred billion dollars per year
that the poor developing
nations can draw from
to do two things, to buy and
purchase new energy technology
such as renewable energy
and for adaptation purposes.
For example, the island nations
that are facing consequences
from sea level rise
will now be able to draw
on technical help from
the advanced nations
as well as money.
And then, finally, there is
nothing in this agreement
called Annex One and Annex Two.
In 1992 agreement, that
I mentioned earlier,
had a definition of, okay,
who's supposed to achieve
this objective and what it said was,
all nations of the world have common,
but differentiated responsibilities.
And for 20-something years now,
the diplomats have been
arguing what does that mean?
So, now there was an Annex One in 1992,
which was the nations that have capital,
that have technology, that
have an educated public,
they were given all the responsibility.
So, it's hardly a
differentiated responsibility
if all the responsibility was on the backs
of the rich people.
The common part of it says that
even the developing nations
have to look ahead and,
while they're developing
their own economy, they have to take
some of this responsibility.
But the feature of creating
this hundred billion dollar fund
and, by the way, it's annual,
it's not a five-year fund,
is that there will be help, technical help
and advisory help, to
these developing countries.
So, on the whole, I think this is a very
intelligent document.
Now, will it succeed?
For example, there's a lot of discussion
around the rest of the world right now
that Obama's term has ended
and he's committed to this agreement,
but will the next president
of the United States
honor these voluntary
contributions or drop out?
Of course, I don't know the
answer to that question,
but I think the, and from
an economist point of view,
this probably isn't as
good as a firmer agreement
that has, for example, trade implications
or something like this,
market implications
that are enforced.
But I think abolishing the
Annex One and the Annex Two
and embracing the rest of this agreement
is a real step forward and I think
there's a good possibility
here that public opinion,
worldwide, will draw
nations to stay with it.
Now, to trigger the agreement,
it's called a to-trigger process,
by April 15th or 16th or 18th,
for this treaty to go
into international effect,
there have to be 55 nations
or more to sign, finally,
and they have to represent 55% or more
of all the global greenhouse
gas emissions from humans.
So, maybe we can argue about whether
it's really meaningful or not.
One other thing is six years ago,
at the National Academy of
Sciences, we released a report
called Verifying Greenhouse Gas Emissions,
and I'm kind of proud of it 'cause,
I think I framed this one,
the idea was what if there
were an international agreement
on climate change, how would
we know if people are behaving?
Remember what President Reagan said,
trust but verify on nuclear weapons.
So, we thought maybe other people
will take the same attitude
that we're gonna have
to have verification.
Okay, how well can we verify
greenhouse gas emissions?
And so, this committee,
and again Professor Fung
here from Berkeley, was on the committee,
scratched their brains and
looked at existing technology
and they made estimates of
how well we are now estimating
the release of greenhouse gases
and I won't bother to
give you their answers,
but they came up with a second proposal,
that paper estimates are very valuable
and they're not being done as
well as they could be done.
So, I think now to this Paris Agreement,
that requires these paper
estimates and will subject them
to international review by experts
and I think this is progress.
I think it's quite realistic
and I'm happy that our report in 2010,
this report will now become
famous six years later,
is my prediction.
So, I think I'll stop here.
I've given you a lot of my own opinions,
but we'll see where we go next.
This was the committee that created
that last report that I mentioned.
Okay, thank you, again.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you very much.
We're really glad to
hear about your optimism
with regard to the Paris situation.
I can remember when Al
Johnston felt so frustrated
because people didn't
believe what he was saying
and I know you must
have felt the same way.
I told him that, being
a theoretical physicist,
we're used to this.
Whenever we come up with a new theory,
and we tell a colleague,
there was only two answers you can get,
it's wrong or I thought of it before.
Well, thank you again.
Questions?
- Anybody who would like to ask a question
can come up to the microphone.
Questions only please and
please keep them brief
and to the point.
Thank you.
- [Man] Thank you very
much for the presentation.
I have a question about how much heat
already in the global system will cause,
through inertial processes
and equilibrium processes,
an inexorable increase
in global temperature
and the point I'm trying
to ask is, in your opinion,
is it still possible to stay
within one and a half degrees
Celsius of temperature increase
above pre-industrial levels?
- I don't think so, but that assumes
that the world consumption of fossil fuels
like petroleum and natural gas and coal,
if you go into the numbers from
a scientific point of view,
to freeze things where
we are now would require
a reduction of about 70 or 80% of all
of our greenhouse gas emissions.
If we just held them constant,
things will continue to rise
for the reasons that you indicated.
We would have to have a drop of 70 or 80%
before the natural processes,
that removal of the greenhouse gases
would begin to have any effect
and I don't think that's possible.
- [Man] Do you think it's still possible
to stay within two degrees?
- Maybe, maybe, but it
depends on the speed.
So, I mean, maybe some people here
have already done the
numerical calculations,
but if you could begin
to cut the emissions
by, let's say, half in the next 20 years,
maybe you could reach it,
but it's gonna be a stretch.
It will be very difficult.
- [Man] Thank you.
- So, will the Paris Agreement
work the way we want it to?
Probably not, but I think it
really is a couple of steps
in the right direction.
- [Man] I too thank you
for this wonderful lecture.
I was in Paris and was
thrilled with the outcome
when they announced it
on that Saturday night,
but I also paid close attention
to what Jim Hansen was saying.
He was there too for
his first COP conference
and was calling it a fraud because the UN
can't put a global price on carbon
and, without a global price on carbon,
he doesn't see how individual nations
reducing their consumption of fossil fuels
is really gonna change
the course of things
and, as I mentioned yesterday,
I work with Citizens Climate Lobby,
I'd like to know your opinion
of the role of carbon pricing
in trying to achieve
these very ambitious goals
that were set in Paris and
how the U.S. could lead
and, by doing so, engage
the rest of the world
since there's nobody that runs the world?
- Well, I will say that
I don't know anybody
who's become rich by
betting against Jim Hansen.
He really knows what he's talking about
and he knows the numbers
as well as anybody,
but I think how we deal with it,
involving human choices
and what will work,
is probably beyond all of our capability.
For example, the United States and China
really kicked off this
approach, this framework,
when Obama met with Xi,
in what, November of 2014.
They agreed that they would
come up with a structure
like this and that they
would both participate.
That is unprecedented.
Those are the two biggest emitters.
So, whatever they do is
gonna have a big impact
on the rest of the world.
Carbon tax.
Do we have any economists here?
Yes.
I would appreciate it if
you would take a minute
and summarize the opinions of economists
as to what's the most effective method,
for example, a cap-and-trade market
and what you mean by effective.
My understanding is the
application of a simple carbon tax,
which is empirically derived,
would be the simplest
and most efficient way to achieve results,
that a cap-and-trade program,
probably, involves a lot more
management and less effective mechanism,
but I do appreciate it, Professor Edlyn,
if you would comment.
- Well, I'm not prepared,
but it's not my field of expertise,
economics I suppose is, but not--
(woman whispering)
What?
Okay, I'll stand up.
So, I think what you said
is, probably, largely right,
that is a carbon tax,
particularly, if it's implemented
at the source where oil is
taken up out of the ground
is, probably, the easiest to manage,
either a carbon tax or cap-and-trade
is infinitely better than nothing,
if you're worried about climate change,
but both of them have the
feature, unlike pure regulation,
that you can lower emissions.
You can equalize the cost
of lowering emissions
so that countries that find
it cheaper to lower emissions
will do most of the reductions.
And so, that's one of
the most important things
if we're going to move forward
is to minimize the cost of it
and both of those, both
cap-and-trade and taxes,
allow some flexibility as
to who does the reductions
and allow the possibility
of shifting money
and lowering costs.
Well, that's the best
I can do on the spot.
- Thanks.
(audience clapping)
Thanks.
Maybe I can add one thing,
that there are economists who are looking
at this situation empirically,
trying to figure out, okay,
if there would be a tax on
carbon, what should it be?
Should it be a penny a
pound or two dollars a ton
or what should it be?
And there's also an organized effort now
in the federal government and, on behalf
of some investment firms, to
try to figure out what this,
what they call the social cost of carbon,
should be set at and there
are lots of uncertainties,
but smart people are working on it.
So, that if there were some
kind of political momentum
or agreement towards a tax
or even a cap-and-trade
with a set price there will
be some grounding empirically
on what the dollar value would have to be,
but I don't think we can predict
how this is gonna come out.
Yes sir.
- [Man] Yes, thank you
for your presentation.
My concern is that if
you step back and look
at what's happened since 1990,
the science has been clear
and the efforts to respond to the science
have fallen further and further
behind the objective process
of global warming.
In Paris, I think, at best,
I mean I'm with Hansen,
it was both in terms of
catching up to the reality
of what we've got to do.
The difference between
the ozone layer and this
is that the ozone layer
was a relatively minor part
of the global economy .
Fast-burning fossil fuels is at the core
and I would just urge
that people have to think
outside the framework of
capitalism or we're in deep trouble
and I would encourage people to talk to me
about Bob Avakian's new
synthesis about that.
Thank you.
- Well, that's pretty much at the core
of a lot of society too
whether you like it or not.
So, I don't think you've
made the problem any easier
is what I'm trying to say,
with your final solution.
- [Man] I don't think
it's an easy problem.
That's what we have to confront, how deep.
- Okay, got it.
- And how wrenching
it actually is.
But there is a way out.
It's just outside of
conventional thinking.
- Thank you.
- [Ron] Let me add my thanks, Ralph.
I have two questions for you.
First is, what's your sense of the success
we can have state-by-state or city-by-city
in approaching this problem
and in meeting the U.S.
or other international targets
and, the second is, can you
comment on where you think
research to support
renewables and new approaches
to avoiding fossil fuels
is going with your hat on
as chair of NAS?
- First of all, the
state and local actions,
I think they really do deserve attention
for several reasons.
One is it shows what the
public has a proclivity to do
and commit to, but also
every success that is gained
by a municipality or a
state in the United States
then becomes an exhibit.
When somebody says it can't
be done, it cannot be done,
and California's already done it
that's a pretty strong case.
So, I think these state and
local actions are very important
and, by the way, it's
similar to what happened
in the ozone layer business.
One example I'll give is,
on my birthday in 1975,
I had to testify in the State
Senate of New York about CFCs
and there was a company there who claimed
that they would suffer
huge financial losses
and they would lay off thousands of people
if they had to give up their products
and I brought with me a
letter from a similar company
from another state who said
they had already achieved it.
There was the exhibit
and those came from local
and state actions.
So, I think they're very important.
What was it on the research
front that you said, Ron?
- I was wondering if you would comment on
where you are going--
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In creating alternatives
and what we need to do as
a scientific community.
- Yeah, well, there are
some really bright spots.
For example, that 100 billion
dollar fund I mentioned,
that's committed to with
this Paris Agreement,
there are already commitments, I guess,
of about $20 billion to it
and some of them are for private concerns.
There's a billion dollar commitment
from the Gates Consortium and it's largely
aimed at energy technology, I believe.
They're funding early stage
and scientific concepts
on new energy technologies
using renewables.
ARPA-E, in the Department of Energy,
that a former Berkeley faculty member
was the first director of, Arun Majumdar,
they've got some fantastic
development projects underway.
Energy storage, of course,
you need energy storage
to be able to use electricity
for transportation.
So, if you could produce
electricity using renewable fuels
or even nuclear power
and you could store it
and you could store large
amounts of it in a car battery
then you could drive around
with an electric vehicle
better than we can now.
So, the point is on many
projects like energy storage,
battery capacity, charging
rates, energy density of storage,
on windmill designs, on improvements
to the electric power grid,
that can distribute electricity
without major losses over more time zones
to make the wind power
more accessible and useful,
on all of those fronts,
ARPA-E under Arun Majumdar,
and it continues, has created targets,
of not only of technical capability,
but financial trade-offs,
at what point does the
price of solar voltaics
enter into competition, with
say, coal-generated electricity
and they can show you the progress
just through this one
government agency, ARPA-E,
inside the Department of Energy.
First of all, it's being
managed beautifully.
They've got investors
involved giving them advice
and trying to buy up
some of the technology.
They've got benchmarks
that they're achieving,
milestones that they're achieving.
So, because of the scale
of the issue, though,
I think private industry
has to be involved,
if not leading it.
You can just have so many demonstrations
by the federal government,
but you have to have adoption
by technology with worldwide sales.
So, that adds to the
complexity of this issue.
Regardless of the economic system,
I think somehow private concerns
have to be helping out here.
- [Woman] Thank you so much
for being here Dr Cicerone.
I'm wondering if you could
speak to what you think
the implications of sort
of growing scientific
and political interest in
climate engineering research
might play in sort of the structuring
of the climate change problem
and proposed solutions,
especially, given the
Academy's reports last year?
- I'll try, by the way, that connects
with what Professor Cohen
was just getting at.
One part of the solution
to the climate issue
could possibly be carbon
capture and sequestration.
That is the intentional
capturing of CO2 emissions
and putting them somewhere else
than in the atmosphere, for example,
and, to just pursue that example,
there are several technologies
that are now being explored,
it may be premature to
call them technologies,
but concepts by chemical
capture, by biological capture,
by burial of carbon, by
doing what some of the people
here at Berkeley are doing
on capturing carbon in soils,
which are known to have
had higher carbon contents
in the past, so it wouldn't
be like tricking nature
to do something that's impossible,
but, instead, to restoring certain aspects
of natural capacity to store carbon.
Certain kinds of
reforestation can contribute.
So, a little bit of this
and a little bit of that.
Energy efficiency is
usually what I start with.
There are still huge
opportunities in energy efficiency
to be to be gained here.
McKinsey & Company, a
global financial analyst
for analytical firm, said
five or six years ago,
that if they were advising clients,
the typical client of McKinsey
would have a bigger return
on investment by
insulating their buildings
than by making any other
financial investment.
So, there are still
potentially huge energy savings
to be had and when the price
of electricity goes up,
people are more willing
to do those things.
So, there is not going
to be a silver bullet,
a magic bullet, that
solves the whole problem,
but it's going to be everything
from energy efficiency,
some conservation, some lifestyle changes
and a lot of technology, I think.
- [Mark] Well, thank you again
and thank you for all your questions
and let's thank Dr Cicerone again.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)